the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
in this video i will be discussing
something george r martin has been
working on that has absolutely nothing
to do with the winds of winter
now the main reason why i'm even making
this video is because i really want to
know how this makes all of you feel
what do you think about george rr martin
working on something else that isn't his
next book
i would love it if you give me your
honest thoughts down below
now as you all know george rr martin has
been writing the winds of winter for
over a decade
this is a book that should have been
released well before game of thrones
ever ended
unfortunately this has led many fans to
believe we will never see this book
a lot of fans think george is working on
everything but the winds of winter
now i mentioned that because george has
said on a number of occasions he will
not be working on anything else until he
gets the next book done
for those of you who don't remember let
me show you something he said back in
2019
when house of the dragon was officially
given the green light by hbo
on george r martin's not a blog website
he said he would not be writing any of
the episodes for house of the dragon
because the winds of winter was still
his main focus
what he actually said was let me make
this perfectly clear
i'm not taking on any scripts until i
have finished and delivered the winds of
winter
winter is still coming and winds remains
my priority
as much as i'd love to write an episode
of house of the dragon
now given that george is very familiar
with the source material
considering he is the one who created it
as well as how great of a writer he is
i don't think it would have been a big
deal if george did write an episode of
house of the dragon
it would not have taken him that long to
write just one episode but i do
understand him not wanting to get
distracted while he is finishing the
winds of winter
he basically said he would not let
anything get in his way of finishing
this book
but has he stuck by this ever since he
gave us that update
well i don't think so aren't you
supposed to be finishing the winds of
winter this entire time
not to add to the chorus of what is
taking so long but this is a 700 page
detour as a matter of fact he has been
writing something that has absolutely
nothing to do with the song of ice and
fire
let alone the winds of winter now i
don't know how many of you saw this but
let me show you an article that was
released yesterday
the headline states george r martin's
next project is confirmed to be released
before the winds of winter
that's right ladies and gentlemen george
rr martin has actually been working on a
video game
as well as all the other things he has
been working on instead of the winds of
winter
this article says he has been writing
the overarching mythos on eldon ring
the first video game he has ever written
for it sounds like george has been
writing the story
themes and maybe even the dialogue now
speaking further about george rr
martin's involvement in the video game
one of the executives at the company
said he told george about his vision for
the game
and that allowed them to have many free
and creative conversations regarding the
game
in which mr martin later used that as a
base to write the overarching mythos for
the world itself
he also went on to say the mythos george
created for the game was full of
interesting characters and drama
along with a plethora of mystical and
mysterious elements as well
that is certainly one thing george rr
martin is very good at
now like i said at the beginning of this
video i want to know what all of you
think about george working on things
other than the winds of winter i mean
let's face it it is his life after all
he should be able to do whatever he
wants my only issue is
he always says he will get the book done
before anything else
he keeps saying that it will be out next
year but then another year goes by
then another year goes by now he's
agreed to work on so many other things
i don't see how the winds of winner can
be his main focus anymore
i should also mention another year has
gone by since george said we could lock
him up
if he hasn't delivered the winds of
winner by now for those of you who don't
know what i'm referring to
let me show you something else george
said back in 2019
this was when george was thinking about
attending a massive science fiction
convention over in new zealand but as
always
he said it would only distract him from
writing the wins of winner
although george always seems to find
time to visit just about every other
convention around the globe
but i digress anyways in the not a blog
george said as for finishing my book i
fear that new zealand would distract me
entirely too much
best leave me here in westeros for the
nonce but i tell you this
if i don't have the winds of winter in
hand when i arrive in new zealand for
worldcon
you here have my formal written
permission to imprison me
in a small cabin on white island
overlooking that lake of sulfuric acid
until i'm done
well that year flew by and the fans made
sure to remind george about what he had
said
missing that deadline by a year happened
the last summer
and here we are again at yet another
summer where george still hasn't
finished the wins of winner
it has now been several years since he
said we could lock him away for not
having delivered the book
well now it should seem very obvious why
he's not getting it done
that's because he's creating other
characters and other mysteries for other
universes that are outside of his own
like he has for the video game elden
ring
this isn't all that he's working on
however he might be busy finishing the
winds of winter
but it's not the only thing george r
martin has in the works
as you all know he is also the
co-creator of house of the dragon
although he has said he will not be
writing any of its episodes
but even that's not a guarantee because
he has said things like that before
now besides house of the dragon hbo also
has
several other game of thrones successor
shows in the works which i am sure
george has his hands on as well i mean
he did just sign a massive 5-year deal
with hbo
i'm sure he will be the co-creator if
any of the other shows get green lit by
the network
george is also helping develop a game of
thrones broadway play
based on the live-action adaptation of
his a song of ice and fire
series george r martin is involved in
other titles
outside of the westeros realm as well
one of which
is an hbo adaptation of who fears death
a 2010 sci-fi fantasy novel earlier this
year
it was also announced that george is
heavily involved in bringing
roger zelazny's sci-fi novel road marks
to the small screen
besides this george is also working on
wild cards books as well
at least one of these stories will be
brought to life on the television screen
only it won't be at hbo george will also
be working on this behind the scenes
in the lost lanes marks the only source
material intended for a feature film
with martin involved
it was also confirmed earlier this year
martin's fantasy short story from 1982
will be brought to life on the big
screen with paul w s anderson
set to direct i will definitely look
forward to that
but as you can see george is working on
so many other things i don't see how the
winds of winter can be his main focus
it's no wonder this book continues to
get delayed year after year
let's face it george is a wanted man his
fame and skill as a writer has brought
him more than enough work for one
lifetime
unfortunately this only means we will
have to wait even longer for the ending
of a song of ice and fire
that is if we will ever see it at all i
have always been very optimistic when it
comes to the ones of winner getting
released soon
but it gets harder and harder to look at
that glass half full
when the years keep flying by let me
know what your thoughts are on all of
this
do you think the winds of winter is
still his main focus
do you think we will get it soon and how
do you feel when his other works are
getting released before the book
leave your thoughts down below as always
thank all of you for watching the video
i hope you have a great day i will see
you again very soon
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
you